cinquante ans tout arrive brigitte
bardot à 50 ans celle qui si longtemps
pour le monde entier fut le sex-symbol
made in france
celle qui selon le mot du général de
gaulle rapportait au pays autant de
devises que l'automobile brigitte bardot
a fêté dans l'intimité
un anniversaire qui d'une certaine
manière marque aussi l'histoire de nos
moeurs france roche brigitte brit-brit
bébé c'était un maquillage une coiffure
un bikini coton rose une samba pour 34
génération elle fut le rêve des jeunes
filles et peuple a les rêves des jeunes
hommes ce n'était pas exactement le même
rêve dieu créa la femme créa le mythe
bardot fait d'amour et de rage de
mariage et de suicide ratée les uns et
les autres elle par contre été réussi
elle déclencha les plus belles bagarres
les plus folles passions les articles
les plus stupides car ce n'était pas
seulement une star mais l'incarnation de
désir confus qui ne pouvait s'exprimer
que dans le scandale
son évolution a été celle d'une bonne
moitié de ce demi-siècle de l'insolence
à la sérénité
elle a symbolisé la libération de la
femme l'abandon des vieilles morale le
droit d'être nu de choisir son amour
j'avais su j'aurais caché mon âge et si
j'avais caché mon âge on m'aurait pas
fait suette mes 50 ans parce qu'au lieu
d'en avoir 50 peut-être on croit que
j'en ai 43
malheureusement j'ai pas caché mon âge
alors évidemment les 50 ans prenait une
dimension les certain que c'est une date
au l'honneur de brigitte bardot la
société protectrice des animaux a décidé
d'ouvrir tous ces refuges samedi et
dimanche pour deux journées d'adoption
exceptionnel